so I just watched Casey neistat's guide
to Instagram video is right here if you
guys want to check it out and I couldn't
agree more instagram has become you know
my favorite social media platform too
for all the reasons you know that he
mentioned that it's pure simple
unsullied by the information dump of
facebook he just said dumb but more than
being just unsullied by the volume of
facebook it's also free of the
performances of facebook too I've talked
about our social media personalities
before in vlog twenty seventy click it
right here if you want to check that out
for Instagram I personally follow three
simple rules three simple don'ts and
I've told these to my friends so I might
as well tell them to you two
rule number one don't take pictures of
yourself rule number two don't take
pictures of food what could possibly be
interesting about your beef bourguignon
what could be interesting about your
pasta South's about your pepperjack
cheese fondue and rule number three and
I think this is this is the hardest one
to follow them don't take pictures that
show you clearly having fun now I still
use Facebook to be sure but I've moved
more toward Instagram because Facebook
sort of became this virtual keeping up
with the Joneses where instead of
getting more and more stuff it was
trying to look more and more cool I
think of the Instagram camera as my eye
I use it to share what I see so that
people my friends can experience what
I'm experiencing do I sometimes break
those rules above I mean no never never
do I ever break those rules of course I
do but they're in my head nonetheless if
you have your own Instagram rules leave
them in the comments below and don't be
afraid of those people who like to say I
don't like to live by any rules and you
can't tell me what to do because that
person always talks like this and they
have to live with that
easy needs that you the New York City
right let's collaborate